we love to leave you with a little
something to take with you in the doggy
bag
[Applause]
and today i picked the gold standard of
backpacks i've never found one better
it's the jansport this is my personal
one actually this is yours for reals
oh yeah cute drew listen um
i am not a bad girl ross okay
this action no
is that you holding the bag on your
elbow what am i doing
i wasn't sure this is crazy i've now
lost
one appendage in hand and listen it's
all about
that they evenly distributed why do i
kind of look like a weird
like a hiker in like the swiss alps
a little bit um all i know is that
when nancy javonan fallon and i used to
start flower films we would walk into
meetings
in big hollywood board rooms and we
would be having these on our backs
and they carried all of our presentation
supplies
and i got to tell you i've never grown
out of it the jansport really is my best
friend
and the bag that i have carried my whole
life so
i highly recommend if you're going back
to school
back to life you're an adult you're a
kid it's the best way to carry your
stuff around and guess what
you're hands-free you know what you're
pulling that bag off
one of my favorite diy projects is tie
dye and i love to do it with rit dye
it's a vegan product it's not tested on
animals it's only 4.99 a bottle a little
goes a long way
really and they have more colors than
you ever knew existed
over 500 and then you can mix more
to come up with your own palette that's
so fun have you ever she made your own
tie-dye
oh there you go wait that's yours no
that was my daughter's
olives she did great olive made all of
those t-shirts with rit dye and she has
incredible techniques and i love her
shirts and just
watching my daughters do this and then i
use it too i'm a long
time like die hard
come on drew are you mad that you didn't
think of that i'm proud of you
and mad at myself yes danny
today it's your pick take it away well
let's go big or go home and so i brought
the biggest
biggest favorite thing it's from 12 15.
and 1215 is one of my favorite favorite
jewelry brands because they use
lab-grown diamonds they're real diamonds
because traditional diamonds are mined
and that's very destructive for the
earth
for me lab grow diamonds are like the
tesla of diamonds
and so we thought diamonds for your
virtual audience
[Applause]
and so this is a quarter carriage 12 15
lab grown diamond set and 14 karat gold
necklace i believe
you have earrings i'm wearing the
earrings they are
so beautiful i put them on early this
morning because i wanted to show
and model them the perfect sunnies to
accessorize for your summer
oh yeah baby candy colored rimless
sunglasses i actually wore these um
on our wildflower shoot those look so
cute
obviously they look cute on you look at
me they look cute
they look so good on your ross they're
ultra light
ultra cute and they come in this huge
variety of colors on amazon
and they protect you uva and uvb
um ross what color oh you're yeah let's
just
throw as many as you can on i'm wearing
blue but i want to look at life through
rose-colored glasses now look
i'm going to go like a light coca-cola
heel
i look like elton john you look so cute